California sheriff's deputy faces of
criminal investigation today after his
bosses said he fabricated a story about
being shot by a sniper 21 year old angel
Renault said he was hit in the shoulder
on Wednesday outside his station in
Lancaster that's north of Los Angeles
the LA County Sheriff's Office says
hundreds of officers responded a
commuter rail line was shut down and
resources were wasted our lead national
correspondent that's David Wagner was
following this story David why in the
world did the deputy do this well Gail
the Y is what the LA Sheriff says they
don't know yet this story seemed pretty
strange from the get-go
investigators say Reynosa has not yet
explained his motive for filing the
false claim he's now lost his job and he
might face criminal charges for filing a
false police report there was no sniper
no shots fired and no gunshot injuries
sustained to his shoulder completely
fabricated Homicide Bureau captain Kent
wagon says much of deputy angel Reynosa
story to police just did not add up much
of his statement was self-serving didn't
make a lot whole lot of sense
Reynosa radioed for help on Wednesday
from the police station parking lot
saying that he had been shot by a sniper
SWAT teams went door-to-door evacuating
people from the building while others
sheltered in place police also searched
the area with a helicopter when a police
officer says he's been shot or shot at
we respond in force there was a large
perimeter to protect this area because
we didn't know where this armed gunman
was Jonte williams lives in that
apartment building my family we had to
be outside the house and I'd say my
mom's house because there wasn't letting
anybody in and out
investigators say Reynosa later admitted
his story was not true
they found no visible wounds on him
though he did have holes in his shirt
from a bullet that he said had grazed
him he later admitted according to
police he cut the holes himself
assistant sheriff Robin Lehman it's
extremely disappointing our deputy
sheriff's are held to a higher standard
and unfortunately in this case he did
not act to that standard Raynaud's had
only been a deputy with the LA County
Sheriff's Department for about a year we
called the LA Sheriff's Union but have
not heard back the LA Lancaster has a
Facebook page the Lancaster Sheriff's
Department and the latest post is about
this story and it starts with five words
angry embarrassed furious unbelievable
and ashamed you could tell they were
very put out about it but it makes you
wonder David how he thought he could get
away with it it's so elaborate him
calling in the 9-1-1 call sounding like
he's out of breath finding out that he
just punched holes in his shirt so the
mayor of Lancaster told the LA Times
that the mayor was told by the Sheriff's
Department that the deputy was having a
really rough first year it's a
probationary period before you become
like a full-fledged deputy so why he may
have acted out like it sounded strange
from the very beginning yeah it was like
a sniper yeah randomly going after a
deputy he's 21 he doesn't have to worry
about the stress of that job anymore
thank you David